this place needs to change and change
fast
yes at least just wait to get it up
first up that it needs to be cleaned so
as a place fit for paying yes to stay in
I put the whole team to work to clean
the in from top to bottom and I'm going
to address the worst problem myself
hello madam thank you it's really chill
as I can put this through at wash yes by
tonight yes like you do a sort of extra
strong cleaning product it's pretty
rancid okay so that be careful will be
that thank you boy
cap we don't catch anything fresh while
the staff finish cleaning the in I want
to have a snoop around the kitchen and
see if there's any more clothes as to
how Ken is running this place
why do I have to ask weekly for the fish
to be eyes down do not take this sign
down do not take my pens by your own if
you use this through replace it or buy a
new one with your paycheck
bloody yeah Charmin can definitely have
issues let's see how if you eat these
cookies take one to your next job
interview I mean my god I'm surprised
anyone still [ __ ] works here this guy
is incredible this is insane
I can't believe Ken is so
passive-aggressive with his staff I need
to talk to him and find out what the
hell is going on I come across all these
little notes about don't take this if
you do take it to you next interview you
tell me what's going on I don't like
being taking advantage of I have some
hard times with things that they do but
why are you talking to them why are you
leading them why are you motivating them
why aren't you getting close to them the
secret of any good management's about
communication understanding and putting
yourself on their level maybe a look at
it as they should be on my level who
you're kidding come with me I will show
you something
take a seat here ten things he's
managing his staff but I think he's
bullying them he needs to see how he's
making them feel I've set up a monitor
in one of the bedrooms and I'm gonna
force came to watch a staff meeting I
think this might bring about the change
this place desperately needs stay here
are we back in five I came here to help
what I'm frustrated about is what I'm
discovering I've stooped around the
kitchen I come across this it's a cookie
jar if you eat these cookies take one to
your next job interview
we call those Kenny's nasty grams all
right
is this a joke what's this no that's
real I put those notes up because my
staff needs reminders for me to tell
them to do the simplest task they can
come off as degrading but I don't know
if they get the hint beyond any other
way what in the hell is going on look at
this one don't take my pens buy your own
I think he hides behind he's afraid of
confrontation
it's passive-aggressive Seth how does
that make you feel he causes us all to
be discouraged in the job set we have
there's so many people here that really
know their jobs well but we have become
discouraged and when people become
discouraged they don't do the things
that are necessary
[Music]
there's no gratitude like so when you
say to us why are we like this
we're just spiritless he's really just
sucked the soul out of every one of us
it really saddens me because I would do
anything for them and I feel that they
don't see that I need to change I
watched everything you said and I
apologize I never wanted to suck the
life at any of you and they can't
control this place but realize maybe I
don't need to control you have a good
team here and if we are gonna move
forward you have to give them ownership
of their own areas Seth
yep you've got to get that mojo back and
I'm falling back in love with what
you've employed to do Karen and you care
and that's what being a good innkeeper
personal touch you should have a hold on
the inside of this business as sort of
filling the place that the inn hotel
manager